in 2003 THQ made Spongebob Squarepants
battle for bikini bottom a game which
has since become a cult classic and a
speedrunners dream rehydrated is a full
remake of that game when I say full
remake I don't mean they ported the old
game so it would work on a new console I
mean the entire game has been rebuilt
from the seabed up to look and play like
a modern platformer the visuals have
been reworked with completely remade
assets and they remastered the
soundtrack so you can jam out while
experiencing all the ridiculousness of
Bikini Bottom and stunning 4k Definition
if you didn't play the original game let
me help you dip your toes in battle for
bikini bottom rehydrated is an original
story based on the first three seasons
of Spongebob which are known as the
classic spongebob era mostly because the
late great Stephen Hill burg was still
heavily involved with the show he was a
marine biologist who was also a voice
actor animator in the mind who came up
with the SquarePants Waring sea sponge
we all know and love
my name's sponge batter in the game you
get to play as your favorite characters
from the show during the glory days of
Sponge Bob
the adventure begins when the tiny evil
genius plankton creates a robot army
using a machine he made called the
duplicator tron 3000 he forgets the
machine is set to don't obey and
releases a horde of disobedient otama
tongs to bring havoc to the good fish of
Bikini Bottom in the game you can play
as spongebob Patrick and Sandy who each
come with unique abilities as you try to
restore order amongst the kelp and tikis
spongebob can wedgie jump using his
underwear uses bubbles as a bowling ball
or helmet to headbutt his enemies and he
can curl up into a sponge ball to roll
around town Patrick can use his starfish
II girth to slam stun enemies he can
pick up and throw objects like giant
watermelons don't question why there are
giant watermelons under the sea just
throw them finally sandy brings her
typical aquatic delving country squirrel
routine to full effect by lassoing bad
guys gliding across distances and swing
from the inevitable hooks that reside in
any platformer worth its weight in
seawater no time to drop to the deck and
flop like a fish we have things to find
battle for bikini bottom is at its core
a collection platformer hidden areas
trampolines buttons and sneaky pressure
pads dot the levels while you run glide
and slide your way across the ocean
landscape collecting shiny objects in
order to pay tolls to clamshells or to
buy golden spatulas which are required
to flip you into new levels of the game
also patrick lost his socks around town
and will trade a spatula for every ten
of the stinky treasures you return to
him Adri you can throw a clam and hit a
game that uses non-fda-approved potions
to regenerate health but we're in bikini
bottom and in order to patch ourselves
up here there is no better tool than
SpongeBob's clean underwear
no matter the assailant be he robot
jellyfish or Tiki a fresh pair of tighty
whities will have us back in shipshape
in no time sandy and Patrick use
SpongeBob's underwear as well and they
complain about it with voices provided
by the original voice actors from the
show with appearances by Squidward mr.
Krabs mrs. puff bubble buddy Larry the
lobster Mermaid Man and Barnacle Boy and
the magnanimous King Neptune you'll
sooner suffer from oxygen deprivation
than a lack of friends on top of
entirely remaking the game THQ nordic
added a new on and offline two-player
horde mode with additional material that
was cut from the original game such as
Robo Squidward who previously only
existed in concept art form I think we
have ourselves a nautical nonsense based
game of the year
SpongeBob SquarePants battle for bikini
bottom rehydrated releases June 23rd on
PC PlayStation Xbox and Nintendo switch
[Applause]